one last item that came up during
yesterday's press availability that
needs to be addressed the contract for
ben roethlisberger for 2021.
one thing that we said as this question
lingered and lingered and lingered was
this only takes five minutes if what
you're doing is taking what he was due
to make this year converting the maximum
that you can to a signing bonus
the rest 1.075 million is salary
everything else gets spread you put on
dummy years on the back end it's very
easy to do very easy to do to create
maximum cap space for ben roethlisberger
without him giving up any money and we
had predicted that the problem was the
steelers wanted to give up money and he
doesn't and i was told at one point hey
the steelers haven't asked him to give
up anything well roethlisberger now
claims that the five million dollars
five million that he gave up in 2021 pay
was his idea here he is talking about
that yesterday
what was your reaction when the steelers
asked you to take a pay cut were you
hurt were you surprised
what were your emotions
ray was my idea
um
i told him i want to help the team out
however we can and so i went to them and
told them that i would do whatever i
could to help the team sign you know the
guys that are going to help us win
football games i've been extremely
blessed to play this game for a long
time and so
um you know that was one of the reasons
i wanted to come back because i knew we
had a obviously a great defense and some
some amazing weapons on offense and so i
wanted to come back to be a part of what
i think is a special football team that
everyone's overlooking which is kind of
cool too and so in order to do that to
help get guys here i felt that it was
necessary to do that
see without getting into the nuts and
bolts of it chris
i think it was more about
the way they did it not having some huge
cap number that they have to deal with
next year if he's gone
i think they could have gotten to the
same place in his cap number for this
year and this is the year he's concerned
about this is the year i mean everybody
everybody assumes this is last year he
said he's operating as if it's his last
year but right every game is potentially
his last game i i don't
i don't buy that it was his idea unless
they put the jedi mind trick on him and
got him to think it's his idea when it
was really their idea well
like
i'm kind of with you on that thought
like right i'm kind of
in my experience or being around
football world
i would think first off this ain't his
first rodeo he knows what's going on he
knows the reality of the situation the
conversation around him right i mean
second thing is
i'm sure he had a little inkling
about wait you know what's going on here
does pittsburgh want me back
you know the agent might have talked to
the team and they're oh you know they're
concerned about your contract situation
and what he basically did is took the
power back into his own hands and said
hey hey hey i'll take less i'll take
less i'll take less i want to be your
quarterback i'll take less i'll take
less and he kind of stopped that
conversation and made it easy on the
team and he took pressure off the
situation altogether by doing that so i
mean i think it was a smart play by him
really maybe the only play maybe a
little bit of a political play to do
that and get out in front of it if it
was his idea but i think it was the
right thing to do for him especially he
wants to play you know he probably
sensed that they were juggling around
some things in the back end a little bit
and he said wait i'll make it simple
here you go i'll play for you know
basically peanuts just bring me back and
that's kind of the way at least i
envision it going down i mean the bottom
line is 5 million dollars went away yeah
five million dollars is gone he's still
gonna make 14
but
five million gone and i don't care how
much money someone has they don't want
to just give up five million dollars
voluntarily you don't get to that point
where you have that much money if you're
that reckless with your attitude toward
five million dollars and it reminds me
of 2015. remember they cut peyton
manning's salary by i think it was four
million yeah but also gave him the
opportunity to earn it back by winning
the super bowl oh and he did right
that's what surprised me about this they
took away the five million with no face
saver they could have put a little face
saver in there that you put in
incentives that earn that money back if
they would win the super bowl and the
fact that that wasn't in there i again i
just think that that was the only way he
was coming back yeah and they were
serious about moving on right they
couldn't get him back at the number they
wanted him at yeah that's why that's
where i think he probably sensed all
those things you just said mike i think
you know again he's he's no idiot this
man we know that and he's a baller and
he loves pittsburgh and he's one of the
greatest players in the history of that
organization so yeah i think he did this
to to kind of just soothe it over and
make the decision a little easier for
the pittsburgh steelers and well done
listen i still got faith in big ben i
know i think i'm thinking i'm sensing
you're on the fence a little bit more
than i am yes i know i get it i get it
i'm not i'm not saying you're wrong um
but we'll see there's definitely some
things a part of that formula and
equation that got to get fixed to make
him work the right way too so we'll see
big ben big ben big ben big ben
as i said back when out of the blue they
decided he was coming back they were
just far enough removed from the way the
2020 season ended to allow themselves
within their echo chamber of the team
facility to say hey you know what
if this play in this game this play in
this game this thing here if we just do
this if we just do that we're good
enough
to not just start 11-0 forget 11 no
we're good enough to win the super bowl
they convinced themselves they can do it
otherwise they would have ripped off the
band-aid and started looking probably
you know alternatives hey they were in
the low 20s
they could have tried to get in position
to get mac jones yeah they had to have
thought about all their possibilities
all their options they had to but they
got themselves convinced at the end of
the day that
our goal is to win a super bowl and
every year we try to win the super bowl
and this year the best way to win the
super bowl is to keep ben around i
predict by november
because of
the physical breakdown of a guy who's
gonna be halfway between 39 and 40. more
than halfway between 39 and 40. they're
going to regret it he's going to regret
it and they're going to regret it that's
my prediction if i'm wrong great but i
can't stifle that belief all right hey
all last year down the stretch crystal
takes expose yep kristen and pete put it
in the vault put it in the vault
it back in there
am eastern june 2 2021 i'm fine with it
play it back and play it back if i'm
right too yeah oh yeah we will
definitely play the back
right you're right okay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports